نحن في الصحراء في وقت مبكر جدًا،
والساعة 36 أو 37 بالفعل
في هذه الصحراء خارج أبو ظبي.
أجد مجموعة من الباحثين يعملون
مع الروبوتات التي تحاكي ما
تفعله بعض الأنواع في
الطبيعة. صباح الخير يا سيدي، مرحبًا،
الوقوف في طابور من  الطريقة التي
تعمل بها مستعمرة النمل معًا لأداء المهام،
فهي تبني سربًا من الطائرات بدون طيار
والروبوتات التي تتعاون وتعمل
معًا بشكل أساسي، فهي تعمل بشكل
مستقل بمعنى أنها تستطيع
القيام بالعمليات بنفسها، فنحن نحاكي
النظام الطبيعي الموجود في الطبيعة
هذه الشبكات الاجتماعية  حشرة مثلا
لديهم ذكاء محدود جدا أه
بمفردهم لكنهم يستطيعون القيام
بعمليات كبيرة معا وما نفعله ما
نحاكيه هو طريقة تواصلهم
وطريقة تنسيق تبادل
المعلومات لديهم وتركهم
ينظمون أنفسهم وأه أداء  أفضل ما
يمكنهم فعله هو تحليل بعض السيناريوهات
التي تتخيل أنها أكثر
الكوارث فعالية، فلدينا
النقل اللوجستي والتفتيش ومراقبة
أي نوع من النشاط حيث نحتاج إلى الجليد
ونحتاج إلى أداء بعض الأنشطة على
الفور  في مختبرات
معهد الابتكار التكنولوجي يتم تجهيز الطائرات بدون طيار
والروبوتات بأجهزة استشعار وكاميرات وأجهزة
اتصال مع كل هذه التقنية،
وفي الميدان يقوم العلماء
بإجراء الأبحاث من خلال إعطاء هذه الآلات
مهام
وتحدي الروبوتات بنفسها دون أن
تكون قادرة على القيام بالتشغيل عن طريق  أنفسهم
لن يعنيوا كثيرًا فكرة
منحهم الاستقلالية لفهم
المشهد وتطبيق ذكائهم من
أجل حل بعض المهام المحددة التي تمثل
خطوة إلى الأمام. كل هذا الابتكار.
الفكرة هي أنه من الممكن بالفعل
الحصول عليه في غضون 5 أو 10 سنوات.  نظرًا لأن
الإنتاج الضخم يمكن لهذه الأشياء أن تفعل ذلك بشكل أفضل وأكثر
كفاءة من البشر، فهو شيء
يمكن للروبوت أن يفعله
بكفاءة أكبر بكثير من حيث التكلفة وبسرعة، فهم لا
يشكون من الحرارة القاسية
التي
ستصبح أكثر أهمية مع تغير المناخ  أليس كذلك
نعم أكثر
صعوبة